[Musica]
nell'ottobre del 2018 le dolomiti
conoscono la tempesta vai a più di 42
milioni di alberi abbattuti da quella
che è stata definita la più violenta
tempesta degli ultimi 50 anni in italia
pensate che 42 milioni di alberi sono
gli alberi che vengono tagliati in
trentino in cinque anni ecco sono stati
spazzati via come stuzzicadenti in una
sola notte
una tempesta anomala anomala favorita
dai cambiamenti climatici in atto nel
nostro pianeta che ha danneggiato anche
in modo devastante dayco sistema quindi
la flora la fauna ha esposto 492 comuni
nel triveneto a rischio idrogeologico è
una tempesta che ha anche cancellato e
spazzato via i luoghi dove molte persone
sono cresciute dove hanno anche speso la
loro le loro vacanze loro tempo libero
per trovare esempio qui siamo a catania
è come se dall'oggi al domani
scomparisse il mare cancellato
totalmente ecco questo è stata la
conseguenza la ferita che questa
tempesta ha lasciato sulle dolomiti
questo danno immenso ci ha spinto a me
federico e paolo a porci una domanda
come è possibile reagire a queste
catastrofi naturali
c'è un modo se si quale com'è possibile
rispondere alle conseguenze
imprevedibili di quello che è una cosa
che purtroppo è eccezionale ma che
destinatari pret a ripetersi con
maggiore frequenza
secondo tutti quanti gli studi
allora abbiamo pensato a un idea che poi
diventata una start up nel 2019 che si
basa su quattro pilastri su quattro
principi molto semplici su come
intervenire in un luogo colpito da una
calamità naturale
prima cosa intrevenire e recuperare una
materia prima che altrimenti andrebbe
sprecata trasformando così un rifiuto
uno scarto in una risorsa e così abbiamo
fatto con il legno caduto durante la
tempesta e abbiamo creato questo
amplificatore l'abbiamo creato
recuperando e restituendo dignità voce
di vita a questi alberi abbattuti e
questo è stato il primo esempio di
economia circolare a cui abbiamo pensato
di dare vita quando abbiamo lanciato
l'idea secondo punto creare un oggetto
iconico vivo che racconti una storia di
un territorio colpito e che quindi
amplifichi un messaggio alla coscienza
collettiva su come poter intervenire in
questi casi facendo qualcosa di positivo
e quindi amplificare quella che è la
voce della natura in pericolo in questo
momento
terzo punto coinvolgere gli artigiani
locali coinvolgere le comunità locali e
quindi creare un sistema positivo per
tutto l'ecosistema non solo dal punto di
vista ambientale ma anche dal punto di
vista sociale perché come immaginate
quella tempesta anche colpito le
falegnamerie ha colpito gli artigiani
quindi come poter risollevare tutto il
territorio
quarto punto fondamentale creare un
impatto positivo vero misurabile
concreto come l'abbiamo fatto
associando la vendita di ogni
amplificatore un albero un albero che
sarà piantato nelle zone colpite dalla
tempesta
come sapete un albero un solo abbellisce
il territorio ma una funzione
straordinaria perché assorbe co2 ci
aiuta a combattere i cambiamenti
climatici aiuta a prevenire disp
idrogeologico è lo strumento naturale
più importante che abbiamo per
combattere i cambiamenti climatici
non solo questo dicevamo che
l'ecosistema delle dolomiti è stato
compromesso da questa tempesta quindi
poter ricostituire gradualmente questo
equilibrio è fondamentale per poter
tornare a un contesto naturale
originario questi quattro pilastri sono
stati applicati oggi nelle dolomiti ma
in futuro vogliamo applicarli in altri
contesti cioè in tutti quei luoghi che
dovranno affrontare le conseguenze
imprevedibili dei cambiamenti climatici
e questa idea si basa sul semplice
principio che è quello di pensare la
produzione di oggetti no come un
qualcosa che tolga la natura che
depauperi un patrimonio naturale ma che
vada a restituire risorse alla natura
che vada reintegrarle quindi è questo il
principio è un principio molto semplice
che non è banale che riguarda proprio il
modo in cui si concepisce la natura c'è
come un qualcosa a cui dover restituire
perché siamo debitori e quindi in questo
caso l'uomo entrò relazione con
l'ambiente non in modo conflittuale ma
in modo armonioso in modo costruttivo e
proficuo per tutti e da questa
esperienza ho imparato due cose che oggi
voglio condividere con voi
la prima è la storia della perla che la
seconda è la storia del fiore vi state
chiedendo che le storie sono cosa che
fare una perla è un fiore con quello che
vi sto raccontando ve lo spiego subito
io spero che noi diventiamo tutti delle
perle non so se sapete come si forma una
perla quando il mollusco che sta dentro
la conchiglia viene attaccato da un
predatore spesso riceve un qualcosa di
esterno percepito come un nemico come un
estraneo
può essere un suggello di sabbia un
parassita e quindi il mollusco che sta
dentro la conchiglia comincia a isolarlo
a contenerlo con delle sfere
concentriche ed è così che nasce la
perla ecco questa è la prima lezione che
ho imparato è che voglio condividere con
voi c'è la resilienza la capacità di
integrare assorbire un avversità
trasformandola in un occasione di
crescita hanno qualcosa di bello in
un'opportunità questo è fondamentale per
affrontare credo le sfide della
sostenibilità in futuro la seconda
lezione fondamentale riguarda proprio
come viene concepita la natura la natura
per noi viene spesso vista come un luogo
dove trovare pace interiore rifugio
spesso anche rispetto ai ritmi frenetici
della vita quotidiana
quindi un luogo dove poter trovare
accoglienza e tranquillità
questa idea è giusta ma va un attimo
problematizza ta in un'ottica diversa
perché e qui torna la storia del fiore
c'è una frase molto bella di uno
scienziato italiano del seicento che
tutti noi conosciamo e galileo galilei e
ci dice le cose sono unite da legami
invisibili non puoi cogliere un fiore
senza turbare una stella
e qui vorrei che questa fase si se
diventasse in ognuno di noi perchè la
chiave per capire che noi facciamo parte
di un unico ecosistema
noi siamo l'ecosistema
questa cosa è fondamentale perché si
capisce che allora nella vita quotidiana
nella vita professionale facendo impresa
facendo varie attività quando noi
creiamo qualcosa dobbiamo crearla perché
sia in armonia con l'ambiente
circostante non sia un qualcosa di
negativo ma si sa qualcosa di positivo
che possa rendere il mondo migliore di
come lo abbiamo trovato è la lezione che
ho imparato con questa startup e proprio
questa che la natura non deve essere
vista come un qualcosa di diverso da noi
come un qualcosa di diverso dalla nostra
casa dal nostro pianeta perché davvero
fa parte del nostro essere tutti in
tutte le forme in tutti i modi possibili
è la cosa fondamentale quella chiave di
cui parlavo per capire che la natura sta
in noi e attorno a noi porta alla
conclusione inevitabile necessaria per
affrontare la sfida dei cambiamenti
climatici che è questo per rispettare e
trattare bene il pianeta
bisogna trattare bene rispettare noi
stessi
[Applauso]
[Musica]